We decided we would indeed
try and have a child,
and then I had to get
my head around the idea
of having sex in order to conceive.
Having sex with that being the reason,
(laughter)
'cause I've only ever had sex
for the fun reasons before,
like being drunk or revenge.
(laughter)
(cheering)
But having sex in order to make a baby,
in my head I was like, "well
that's sounds something
"that should be very, very serious!"
(laughter)
I said to my husband,
"There will be no fun
"involved in this.
(laughter)
"No talking dirty, that'll be like
"bad parenting before
we've even become parents."
(laughter)
I just build it up in my head,
I just imagined, sort of the whole act
to be something very, very solemn
that will be done in complete silence,
with your eyes closed.
And the man will just be like,
(grunting)
(laughter)
(heavy breathing)
It is done.
(laughter)
(cheering)
And then you shake hands
(laughter)
and light a candle in memory
of your disposable income.
(singing)
(laughter)
Turns out though, in
reality, "making a baby" sex,
exactly the same as normal sex,
just with more existential dread
and a headstand at the end.
(laughter)
And with my husband whispering
"swim, my little champions."
(laughter)
But his champions did
swim, or at least one
knackered old bastard
managed to get through,
and here we are.
I'm at the stage now where I can feel
the baby moving inside me,
and I'll be honest, it's fucking weird.
(laughter)
I don't know if I like it.
You're meant to love it, aren't you?
My husband says to me,
"does it feel magical?
"Does it feel magical?"
I'm like, "well if by magical,
"do you mean does it feel like
I've swallowed a live fish,
(laughter)
"that is freaking out inside
me, and headbutting my bladder,
"then yes, it's a regular
fairy tale, darling!"
(laughter)
Does feel very odd, it does,
but I've gotta get used to this now,
'cause I'm over half way, which
means in just a few months,
I will finally be able to cradle
a wine.
(laughter)
(cheering)
I can't stop thinking about it!
(laughter)
I'm like "oh my god,
what will it look like?
(laughter)
"How big will it be?
"Will I be able to cope
with more than one?"
I am finding the no
drinking thing quite hard,
which I wasn't expecting,
'cause all my friends who've had children,
said "you don't miss alcohol
when you're pregnant,
"don't miss alcohol at all!"
I can confirm, that is absolute bullshit!
(laughter)
People ask me if I have cravings.
Yeah, two quite strong ones,
pinot and grigio, thank you!
(laughter)